the corona virus pandemic has closed
countless businesses and put millions of
Americans out of work earlier I sat down
with billionaire entrepreneur Mark Cuban
to discuss what kind of an economic
recovery we should expect and when Mark
Treasury secretary minuchin said this
week he thinks the economy will be back
open for business in May do you think
it'll be that soon and how will you
decide when to send your people back to
work
I mean it's semantics will it be open 24
hours a day no will we will we open some
doors and take some baby steps yes
how will I decide it's very simple when
the scientists say it's safe for my
employees to come back to work
that's when I'll feel confident enough
to let them go back to work the US
economy I don't have to tell you is
taking a huge hit 17 million people
filing for unemployment benefits over
the last three weeks Goldman Sachs
predicts that the GDP in the second
quarter instead of going up two percent
or three percent is going to go down
about 30 percent contract by about a
third
president Trump says that when we do get
a recovery it's going to be a fast one a
v-shape sharp down sharp up here he is
talking about that I think we can get
more than back to normal from an
economic sample it actually be better
but more than back to normal I think
we're going to go like a rocket ship
once we get back to business there's a
lot of pent-up energy and demand
do you see a quick recovery or do you
think it's gonna be a little bit slower
than that I wish you was right but he's
not I think it's going to be slower I
think there's going to be so many
different ways we have to adapt to this
new abnormal people aren't gonna just
venture outside they're not going to go
to large gatherings they're not going to
feel confident right off the bat there's
gonna be a lot of trepidation and that
concern is going to lead to you know
people holding back and spending money
you know there's been they we're not
going to know if the virus is coming
back
on top of that when it comes to hiring
people back companies aren't going to
just immediately bring everybody back so
there are a lot of people who are hoping
they go back to work it just won't be
able to and I think that's gonna create
problems but you do talk about a
transition and if it's not a quick
recovery and eventual recovery and you
keep talking about America 2.0 what does
that mean
so there will be a lot of change there
will be a lot of uncertainty but out of
that uncertainty will come new great
businesses if there's one thing that
sets this country apart from any other
country in a world the fact that we're a
country of entrepreneurs were creative
we're innovative we like to take risks
and chances to create new businesses and
that's exactly what would we'll do and I
have no doubt in my mind that in five
years or ten years we'll look back and
there'll be 25 or 50 companies that got
started out of the pandemic of 2020 that
are just amazing and world-changing but
that said it's gonna take us time for
all those companies to have their impact
so I don't see a v-shaped recovery but I
have no doubt in my mind that will come
back and be stronger than ever but it's
not going to happen immediately all
right well let's talk about the recovery
as it comes in stages that you're best
known as being the owner of the Dallas
Mavericks NBA basketball team president
Trump talks about the hunger to get back
to life as normal including life in
people supporting and going to games
take a look so they want to sit next to
each other like normal at a football
game baseball game basketball game
hockey game no we want to go back to
life but you know you were talking about
people not immediately going embracing
the idea of big crowds 20,000 people in
an arena sitting right next to a
stranger so do you think the NBA returns
this season how do you do that with
social distancing and could you envision
a situation where everybody who comes in
has to have their temperature taken well
a couple questions there Chris do I see
us getting back to a season I don't want
to make any predictions but I'm hopeful
that we will but I don't think we'll
play in front of fans I think initially
we'll play just for the tea
cameras with essential personnel and
players and I think that's a great thing
because I think we need things to cheer
for we need teams to get excited about
we wanted a communal experience that we
can all root for our favorite teams
that's gonna be a big step and I think
the MBA recognizes that that's a
responsibility we have and that will
undertake as soon as it's safe because
we won't do anything to jeopardize the
safety of our players or employees now
part two to that in terms of when do we
get back to that sense of normalcy where
we can all crowd into a stadium or an
arena once we have confidence in the
medicine then I think that's when it
happens when you know again American
exceptionalism is outstanding you know
we the scientists are going to come up
with solutions and when they do and when
we have that confidence people will go
back we're already taking their
precautions and already going through
the process at the American Airlines
Center to say okay what do we need to do
in terms of sterilization
standardization repeat cleanings in
terms of informing people that you know
the the seat that they're in has been
cleaned you know two hours ago or three
hours goes whatever it may be and so
we'll take those necessary steps so once
once the science is in place and we
start to feel confident then the
facilities and the arenas at stadiums
etc we'll take the steps to make sure
that it's clean and then once we start
going through confidence we'll build you
have also invested in about a hundred
and fifty small businesses as part of
your work on on Shark Tank I know that
you support the two trillion dollar
program bail out whatever you want to
call it a big chunk of which is for
small businesses but I also know you
think it would work better instead of
this payroll Protection Plan where small
businesses have to apply for a loans if
instead they just got overdraft
protection how would that work very
simply so with your bank where you
already have a checking account you
would work with the bank to designate
here is my rent my landlord that I write
checks to here are my utilities that I
write checks to here's what I do for
payroll and for those checks they won't
bounce and the reason you do it that way
is you reduce all the friction right now
we're seeing all the friction from the
banks were to distribute loans were
and then distribute the PPP loads and
how it's slowing everything down and
that's leading to companies being laid
off
I mean employees being laid off and
companies closing with pay with an
overdraft protection program companies
could just continue as usual pay their
payrolls pay their insurance pay their
utilities rent etc and they wouldn't
have that fear that they won't be able
to make those payments and so I always
just felt that the overdraft protection
program would work a whole lot better
you also say that the government should
take a hard line when dealing with big
corporations for instance the airlines
which the president is talking to this
weekend don't let the CEOs do anything
to set the terms for how they're going
to be bailed out yeah without question I
mean look they're coming for money for a
reason and this is taxpayer money so I'm
not saying don't give them money but
there needs to be terms and conditions
that really put the taxpayer first if
we're going to give them alone
that's great but let's ask ask for
equity let's ask for equity kickers I'll
use Warren Buffett as an example when he
helped bail out Bank of America in the
early 2010 time frame he gave them five
billion dollars alone but he also got
warrants and options and other things
that he then turned into a twelve
billion dollar profit we should be able
to do that for American citizens and
part two to that Chris is you know it
also can show other benefits for the
airlines the government buys a lot of
commercial air travel so it's not
inconceivable that we as part of this
deal we can prepay for commercial travel
and workout programs with the airlines
to have federal employees travel to
build confidence in the airlines again
so have the government prepay however
many hundreds of millions of dollars
that we typically spend with those
airlines work on a sanitation program to
make sure that the insides of those
airlines are safe when we go to fly them
have federal employees fly in those
newly safe airlines and develop
confidence so that that making can be
vague conveyed to the general public
then they're going to be more likely to
travel battle each of the airlines
coming back sooner finally you talk back
in
about running for president of when you
finally decided not to do so and the
other day you said you were
reconsidering now I don't have to tell
you I suspect you know this already that
the deadline for filing as an
independent candidates has already
passed in some states and is about to in
other states so I know Mark Cuban likes
publicity as much as the next person
maybe more than the next person yeah
you're not really serious about this are
you
hey unique circumstances you just never
know Chris I never would have considered
it prior to a month ago but now things
are changing rapidly and dramatically so
there's different ways to get through
those issues you mentioned so I'm not
saying no but it's not certainly
something that I'm actively pursuing I'm
just keeping the door open but are you
saying that this is something that is
serious as it is today I'd say probably
not that it's not going to happen but
again so much can change you you just
never know we this is not something
we've seen before these this is
obviously a unique set of circumstances
and so I'm just not going to say no it's
just you just don't know what can happen
between now and November Mark Cuban
you're always interesting and you're
always provocative thanks so much for
sharing part of your Easter weekend with
us hey thanks for having me Chris and
stay safe